et avec nous pierre Jacquemin bonjour
Pierre merci d'être là rédacteur en chef
de politique et l'éditorialiste
Dominique de mon vallon bonjour
Dominique merci d'être avec nous Steve
nous a rejoint on va parler dans ce club
du plan de Gabriel Attal contre la
fraude fiscale l'objectif cibler la
fraude des plus riches et la pression
sur les classes moyennes vous ne direz
ce que vous en pensez et puis on parlera
de ce débat qui a eu lieu hier à
l'Assemblée nationale sur l'obligation
du drapeau français et européen sur les
frontons des mairies c'est une volonté
du groupe Renaissance pas forcément
partager sur tous les bancs de
l'Assemblée cible vous avez suivi cette
séance vous allez nous raconter tout ça
d'abord on regarde l'actualité dans nos
régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans la région du côté de
Poitiers on retrouve Delphine Blanchard
bonjour Delphine merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous journaliste à La Nouvelle
République Delphine vous revenez ces
jours-ci sur cette épreuve que la France
a traversé c'était déjà il y a trois ans
la crise sanitaire et le confinement
oui il y a trois ans le 11 mai 2020
c'est un cheval premier confinement il y
en a eu un deuxième six mois plus tard
et un troisième au printemps suivant
certains d'entre nous l'avaient même
presque oublié pas les confinements bien
sûr hein forcément marquants mais les
dates le nombre les durées tout cela
autant que les masques les passent les
vaccins ça semble très très loin donc
trois ans après que reste-t-il de cette
crise dans nos vies on a décidé à la
rédaction de la Vienne de se replonger
pendant toute la semaine sur cette
période et de faire témoigner ceux qui
sont encore en plein covid et c'est le
cas notamment de Guillaume et Anaïs un
couple de cadrage génère qui habite
Poitiers pour eux la vie n'a pas repris
son cours normal après le covid la
maladie les poursuit il raconte ce
combat celui qu'on appelle le combat de
contre le covid long Anaïs et Guillaume
garde le masque tout le temps pour
sortir pour accueillir du monde chez eux
dans leur appartement à Poitiers seuls
pour la séance photo avec notre
photojournaliste ils ont bien voulu le
retirer quelques secondes seulement pour
eux la vie n'a comme avant comme nous
tous pour eux le covid n'est pas un
mauvais souvenir pour Anaïs et Guillaume
Le covid a fait son nid dans leur vie
pour ne plus en sortir Anaïs elle reste
alité 80% de la journée Guillaume se
couche à 20h avec une sieste
l'après-midi la vie sociale il y a un
gap entre le monde et nous raconte-t-il
dans nos colonnes ils expliquent même on
n'est pas juste fatigué si on tire sur
la machine ça déclenche tout un tas de
douleurs ce n'est pas juste une fatigue
c'est un épuisement il se battent au
quotidien pour faire reconnaître le
covidon comme une maladie de longue
durée c'est leur combat désormais et
Delphine cette période a aussi été
marquée par des histoires positives et
c'était également un lien dans vos pages
c'est ça il y a eu un grand mouvement
d'entraide assez spontané qui s'est mis
en place à plusieurs niveaux dès le 17
mars 2020 par exemple des couturières on
cause du des masques des propriétaires
d'imprimante 3D ont créé des visières
des bonnes volontés on cuisiné pour des
personnes isolées des musiciens on aime
jouer sous les fenêtres des maisons de
retraite et des producteurs fermiers
encore ou ont organisé des drives qu'on
reste-t-il aujourd'hui donc dans la
Vienne on est allé voir Sandrine par
exemple qui a fait partie des dizaines
de couturières mobilisées dans le
département de l'Aube à la nuit pour
concevoir des masques en tissu sandrine
est infirmière en cardiologie et elle
voulait apprendre à coudre ça tombe bien
la formation a pu se faire en accéléré
et sur le tas à partir d'un modèle de
masque où on inséré un filtre entre deux
couches de tissu aujourd'hui trois ans
plus tard elle raconte c'était une folie
j'en ai fait pour mes collègues j'en ai
fait tout au long de la journée j'ai dû
confectionner plus de 3000 masques avec
l'aide de ma fille et de mon mari elle
raconte celle qui aujourd'hui elle est
toujours infirmière mais à 80% de son la
grandement développée son activité de
couture faire ses masques lui a donné
une visibilité une notoriété puis
surtout l'occasion de de se reconvertir
avant pour cent et le partage l'envie
d'aider c'est ce qui a motivé aussi les
cuisinières du cœur parmi lesquels Samia
qui avait fondé un groupe pour venir en
aide aux sans-abris aux étudiants de la
Vienne lors de la crise sanitaire c'est
un groupe de femmes qui ont cuisiné
jusqu'à 100 repas par soir et apporter
un peu de chaleur humaine à des
centaines de personnes isolées et
démunies aujourd'hui Samia raconte que
les actions continuent le réseau de
cuisinière continue toujours à
fonctionner et notamment en ce moment en
période d'inflation il y a des nouveaux
problèmes qui sont survenus les
étudiants sont également défavorisées
donc il n'arrête pas et
professionnellement samia est la même pu
créer son activité de traiteurs pour
certains vous le voyez donc Oriane le
covid a été un véritable changement de
vie et même parfois positif on va
essayer de retenir ça merci beaucoup
Delphine on regarde la Une de La
Nouvelle République aujourd'hui cette
question pourra-t-on se baigner cet été
vastes questions merci beaucoup merci
Delphine Blanchard d'avoir été avec nous
et à très vite évidemment dans cette
émission on va commencer ce club par le
plan de Gabriel attaque le plan de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale qui a donc été
dévoilé hier et l'objectif est clair
pour le ministre cibler la fraude des
ultra riches et allégées la pression sur
les classes moyennes il y aura plus de
contrôle fiscaux sur les au revenu
également sur les multinationales sa
cible qui se plan pierre politiquement
parlant
sa cible l'opinion publique c'est à dire
qu'on voit bien à peu près la stratégie
qui est celle de Gabriel etal depuis
quelques temps
séduire un électorat montrer que après
la réforme des retraites on va
s'attaquer à l'argent des plus riches
mais moi je m'étonne quand même parce
que il présente cette mesure de de
contrôle fiscal d'aller chercher
l'argent qui manquerait dans les caisses
de l'État sur sur de la fraude fiscale
comme si c'était quelque chose de
nouveau enfin j'espère que depuis que
l'État existe et depuis que
l'administration fiscale existe c'est le
boulot ça c'est mais
Dominique c'est peut-être la seule bonne
annonce qui est faite par la tête mais
oui parce qu'il dit je vais renforcer
les effectifs après les avoir lui-même
enfin en tout cas Emmanuel Macron et ses
amis depuis qu'ils sont gouvernement
d'avoir alléger les effectifs de Bercy
de Bercy donc c'est tant mieux si il
renforce ça mais pardon mais il nous
fait un discours de gestionnaire Gabriel
Attal en réalité
[Musique]
qui vient de distinguer le français
l'économiste français qui vient de voir
la plus grande distinction mondiale le
deal lui-même la France est devenu un
pays hyper attractif pour les Ultra
riches parce qu'il paye entre deux et
trois pourcents d'impôts ce qui est
absolument ridicule donc il y a une
marge de manœuvre très progressive à
faire c'est parce que fait Gabriel
Dominique qui n'a pas bondir
et parfois il passion
j'ai pas besoin de me contenir pour ça
d'abord moi ce que j'aime c'est ultra
riche on connaissait dans le vocabulaire
politique on connaissait l'ultra gauche
on connaît depuis longtemps et plus
particulièrement depuis quelques jours
l'ultra droite et maintenant voilà
maintenant les Ultra riches c'est pas du
même mais il a réussi à imposer avec
cette avec cette formulation une
démarche politique qui était nécessaire
mais qui n'aurait pas eu autant d'impact
la deuxième chose c'est que il y a il
faut que la France et c'est le cas
continue d'être complètement attractive
elle va être attractive pour tout le
monde on pourrait détailler certaines
choses mais je veux dire y compris pour
les plus riches il faut pas que les plus
riches dans notre pays et notamment les
grandes sociétés en profite pour passer
entre les avec des conseillers fiscaux
dont qui se multiplient depuis quelques
années qui leur donne des façons de
contourner de se faufiler etc dans les
mailles du du filet réglementaire et
législatif il ne faut pas que ce soit
pour autant une façon de se dérober à
leurs obligations non moi je trouve la
démarche intéressante comme toute
démarche politique je la jugerai comme
tout ce citoyen le moment venu au
résultat on verra est-ce qu'il y a pas
aussi une volonté de dire à l'opinion
publique que Macron n'est pas le
président des riches cette étiquette
qu'il a eu son temps
les Français se feront leur propre avis
là-dessus j'ai été frappé aussi du fait
du distinguo très net c'est c'est du
Attal
il a choisi de ne pas faire dans la
nuance et excessive et après tout c'est
comme ça qu'on se fait comprendre dans
un monde tourneboulé il a choisi de bien
distinguer les classes moyennes donc il
rappelle le rôle historiquement et
aujourd'hui potentiellement décisif dans
la société française et au-delà mais
enfin on parle de la France là et les
ultra-riches oui c'est sur lesquels il
allège la pression sur les classes
moyennes il y a des mesures je suis oui
il y a certaines mesures qui sont prises
je suis pas sûr que les classes moyennes
en question et le sentiment que la
pression s'allège tant que ça sur eux
sur elle serait plutôt pas en tout cas
c'est intéressant c'est intéressant une
forme de droit
c'est intéressant dans cette histoire de
voir encore une fois on verra les en
jugera
la démarche assez résultat dans quelques
temps mais ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est les données qui sont mises en
lumière il y en a au moins deux il y en
a d'autres mais il y a au moins un an il
y en a trois il y a la fraude fiscale
c'est un vrai problème pardon de dire
des choses aussi banales mais c'est un
vrai problème et la combattre il y a pas
il y a pas qu'en France que cette
démarche existe aujourd'hui on la voit
aux États-Unis et ailleurs mais la
combattre est une nécessité démocratique
deuxièmement les Ultra riches le concept
d'ultra riche je le trouve intéressant
dans la bouche
de Gabriel Attal et c'est intéressant ça
renouvelle un peu le débat et puis et
puis
dire que les classes moyennes ont besoin
d'être défendus ça veut pas dire qu'elle
doit frauder
puisqu'on parle de fraude fiscale etc
mais elles ont besoin des défauts elles
sont aujourd'hui prises en étau entre
les Ultra riches puisque c'est le
nouveau concept je l'utilise et à
l'autre bout ceux qui sont plutôt je
méfie de ce que je vais dire alors de la
façon de la formation
euh les les assister enfin ceux qui sont
un peu plus et voilà ça
me fait bon mais les entreprises les
assistés
je n'ai pas détaillé pour que tout le
monde reste sur son siège voilà d'abord
il y a un volet aussi qui concerne les
annonces de Gabriel qui sont des simples
transpositions de directives qui sont
celles de l'Union européenne vous prenez
la TVA par exemple la fraude à la TVA
l'Union européenne a d'ores et déjà mis
en place un dispositif qui est déjà
appliqué dans plein de pays oui mais
pardon et je l'ai déjà dit sur ce
plateau mais la macronie Emmanuel Macron
c'est ministre sont les premiers des
populistes de ce pays ils font de la
démagogie pure Gabriel en France alors
mais pardon oui enfin vous revenez sur
le comment est arrivé Emmanuel Macron
sur le sur la en se présentant
dehors en allant faire la révolution
bref mais Gabriel Attal il nous a dit
quoi il y a quelques jours il nous a dit
qu'il allait aller voir les français
pour demander aux Français quels étaient
leurs priorités pour justifier les
budgets à l'éducation plus voilà bon
pardon mais ça ça s'appelle une élection
présidentielle c'est ce sont des choix
qui sont arrêtés au moment d'une
élection présidentielle donc il fait des
annonces comme ça on va les consulter
les Français on sait pas très bien
comment ni quoi et ni ce qu'ils ont fait
est-ce que c'est dit
est-ce que vous êtes cons et ça séduit
parce qu'à ce moment il dit aussi que il
va les faire la poche des des riches et
la poche des fraudeurs aux prestations
sociales donc évidemment il va séduire
un électorat populaire là il fait des
annonces en disant regardez vous allez
voir on va mettre les moyens pour aller
chercher l'argent des riches quand ils
le donnent pas alors que c'est juste une
question de l'égalité que de payer ses
impôts en France quand on est riche on a
des impôts à le faire et que donc c'est
juste normal que de le faire et et et il
a pris la salle il se positionne en
super chef de l'administration en disant
vous allez voir avec mes petits bras je
vais chercher l'argent des plus riches
mais il dit pas je vais réformer la
fiscalité parce que les brides ne
payaient pas suff et de toute façon il
le fera pas parce qu'ils ont tout fait
depuis qu'ils sont au gouvernement pour
alléger les recettes de l'État c'est
bien le problème d'aujourd'hui c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le plus souvent plus vous
enlevez des des des impôts l'ISF la flat
tax etc bah forcément vous retirez de
l'argent dans les caisses de l'État
alors que aujourd'hui on a plus on a
besoin justement d'aller chercher de
nouvelles recettes qui rentrent dans les
caisses de l'État si on veut réduire les
déficits si on veut financer les
services publics on peut chasser les
impôts nous proposer encore plus
d'impôts mais c'est incroyable
les 400 familles les plus riches de
français
Gabriel zuckman celui qui vient de
décorer de la plus grande médaille
internationale un économiste français
dont vous devriez être fier Dominique
parce que c'est un écomiste Français qui
le dit 400 français je suis économiste
français la plus grande distinction en
économie c'est quand même pas mal et
c'est lui qui dit les 400 familles les
plus riches de France sont imposées
entre deux et trois pour cent vous êtes
à combien
30% quasiment sur sur et imaginez mais
je suis très loin de dans le groupe que
vous venez d'évoquer qui vous fait VIB
politiquement alors même passé une autre
annonce sur un autre sujet du
gouvernement hier c'est une annonce de
Gérald Darmanin qui demande au préfet
d'interdire les manifestations d'ultra
droite après la polémique liée à la
manifestation qui a eu lieu samedi à
Paris on va écouter la réaction de Bruno
Retailleau le président du groupe les
républicains en Sénat il était hier soir
sur BFM un certain nombre de ceux qui
sont indignés on l'indignation sélective
une indignation parfois
géométrie variable parce que celles et
ceux qui parfois se sentent indignés
sont les mêmes qui ont tendance à
excuser à relativiser les violences des
extrémistes de gauche lors d'un certain
nombre de manifestations récentes à
sainte-solines ou au 1er mai donc je
crois que lorsqu'on a une position on
l'a pour tout le monde
sur le même plan ce qu'il appelle
l'ultra droites ou moi je les appelle
les néonazis ce sont clairement des
néonazis qu'on défilant les rues de
Paris samedi dernier et face aux
militant écologiste de sainte-soling il
y a des militants qui portent des
revendications
humanistes des revendications
environnementales des revendications
écologistes absolument nécessaire
de l'autre côté vous avez des gens qui
font des salut nazis qui organisent des
concerts rock arien comme il y a eu
après la manifestation de samedi et il
les met sur le même plan je voudrais
juste rappeler à Monsieur Retailleau et
aussi à ce gouvernement que quand même
ils ont fait preuve de d'hyper
inventivité pour interdire un certain
nombre de manifestations de casseroles
en ayant activité parce que comme il
fait quand même le chercher les
fonctionnaires qui vont chercher les
mots
instrument sonore portatif on interdit
les sifflets les cartons rouges etc ils
ont fait preuve d'une d'un inventivité
assez incroyable pour interdire un
certain nombre de manifestations de gens
qui étaient opposaient la forme des
retraites mais là pour une manifestation
vous avez 500 militants militants
fascistes militants néonazi proche de
Marine Le Pen pour certains d'entre eux
qui défilent dans les rues de Paris on
trouve aucune excuse pour pouvoir
interdire ce type de manifestation alors
même que le préfet la veille avait
publié un arrêté autorisant l'usage de
drones pour contrôler des possibles
dérapages qui auraient conduit qu'il
avait déjà pris un arrêté d'interdiction
de précédente fois qu'il avait été cassé
pour la justice mais c'est pas grave
enfin ce que je veux dire c'est que il a
bien réussi à le faire pour d'autres
mobilisations récentes contre la réforme
des retraites et encore une fois il
avait là encore l'opportunité puisque
lui-même a pris un arrêté autorisant
l'usage des drones ça veut dire que s'il
prend cet arrêté pour contrôler la
population c'est bien qu'il avait le
pressentiment ou en tout cas que ses
services lui avait indiqué qu'il y avait
la possibilité de de troubles à l'ordre
public donc ah non je mélange pas tout
non non je mélange pas tout ils avaient
des indices qui est pardon mais on les
connaît il les connaissent ces groupes
ultra ultra-droites néo d'Asie c'est pas
c'est pas des Gentils qui défilent
d'ailleurs on l'a vu il défie avec des
cagoules il y a des on a entendu des
slogans que on a pas envie de de
rappeler ici donc moi ça ça exaspère et
c'est surtout c'est c'est je dis
beaucoup que ce gouvernement se fait
complaisant avec l'extrême droite mais
là il ne se fait plus que complaisant il
est complice de l'extrême droite en
intervenant pas en amont de ce type de
manifestation le mal est fait monsieur
Darmanin a beau dire qu'il va à
l'intérieur toutes les manifestations de
l'extrême droite faut-il encore
s'entendre sur ce qu'il appelle
l'extrême droite ou l'ultra droite je
sais plus quel est le terme si il a
utilisé les deux termes il y a l'assemb
total il pourra faire tout ce qu'il veut
aujourd'hui le mal est déjà fait moi je
dirais que vous seriez plus percutant du
moins à mes yeux c'est pas très
important
si tenant le discours que l'analyse que
vous tenez vous aviez commencé par
distinguer à Sainte Soline on va pas y
revenir mais puisque c'est vous qui
l'avez lancé à Sainte Soline les
manifestants dont on peut penser ce
qu'on veut de leurs objectifs de leur
slogan de leur façon d'être du petit
groupe important et influent en leur
sein qui était des véritables casseurs
et qui avait comme objectif de casser du
flic bon et vous seriez plus à l'aise
pour dire ce que maintenant sur
l'histoire de l'extrême d'abord je vais
vous dire quand moi j'ai découvert comme
beaucoup de Français j'ai découvert dans
les images de télévision ça c'est
extrêmement troublant ça ça fait froid
dans le dos qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
que ces types dont certains et beaucoup
même en leur sein étaient cagoulés qui
avec les slogans que évoqué etc donc il
y a il y a il y a quelque chose qui il y
aura un avant et un après mais
s'agissant de cette manif moi je suis
pas du tout d'aucun point de vue la
moindre complaisance vis-à-vis de ce de
l'horlogique de leur slogan de leur
façon de faire et leur façon de se
regrouper mais j'ai compris parce que
maintenant nous instruit de nous
instruit que chaque année il se
retrouvait les autres années moins
nombreux le seul point commun entre
cette année et les années précédentes
ils étaient donc plus nombreux cette
fois c'est qu'il y a pas eu d'incidents
violents prenons prenons acte quand même
de ce fait mais il y aura j'insiste un
avant et un après il est pas possible
pour pour tout citoyen quel que soit sa
sensibilité républicaine il n'est pas
possible de voir défiler dans les rues
de Paris des des individus avec des
cagoule qui nous permettent pas même
d'entre eux d'entrevoir même leurs yeux
etc c'est c'est et les slogans qui ont
été év il y a un problème Dominique vous
dites il y a pas eu d'incident violent
mais le seul fait que des propos ont pu
être tenus sur les races sur les c'est
pour ça qu'il y aura l'argent
public
j'ai pas dit que c'était anodin c'est
pas que qu'il fallait pas en tirer les
conseillers
ou des McDo cassés qui sont considérés
comme étant trouble à l'ordre public
c'est aussi des propos qui sont
respectueux des propos qui sont racistes
des propos qui sont excluents bien sûr
allez dernier thème de ce club c'est une
question à laquelle était invité à
répondre des députés hier si oui faut-il
rendre obligatoire les drapeaux français
et européen sur la façade des mériques
question posée par le député Renaissance
Mathieu Lefebvre qui a déposé une
proposition de loi en ce sens
aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est obligatoire
mais seulement dans les écoles et les
collèges et il y a beaucoup de symboles
dans cette proposition de loi tout
d'abord la date d'examen le texte était
donc discuté hier 9 mai qui était la
Journée de l'Europe cette fête qui est
célébrée dans tous les pays de l'Union
pour rendre hommage au premier pas de
l'unification européenne dès le début de
la discussion hier la majorité
présidentielle a tenté de présenter les
choses comme un référendum pour ou
contre l'Europe écouter le vote qui sera
le vôtre tout à l'heure sera votre en
faveur ou en défaveur de la construction
européenne ni plus ni moins il
départagera ceux qui considèrent
que
faire diversion personne n'est dupe tout
le monde aura compris que ce projet de
loi n'a aucune utilité pratique d'abord
la grande majorité des mairies de France
sont déjà pavoisées sans qui existent
quelconque obligation de le faire en
dehors de certaines journées symboliques
alors pourquoi ne pas laisser cette
liberté aux communes les mers qui pour
beaucoup se demandent comment ils vont
équilibrer leur prochain budget dès lors
que vous laissez les fournisseurs
d'énergie se gavés sur le de tout le
monde ont d'autres urgences à traiter la
motion a été rejetée par les députés
mais point intéressant elle était votée
par le rassemblement national pour des
raisons différentes les députés RN
estiment que le drapeau européen ne
renvoie tout simplement à rien écouter
que voulez-vous les Français ne
partagent pas votre rêve d'étouffer les
nations et le partageront jamais il n'y
a que trois couleurs trois couleurs face
auxquelles les Français s'inclinent
devant leur mort dans leur école dans
nos cérémonies le blanc le bleu le blanc
et le rouge
faut-il donc rendre obligatoire les
drapeaux français européens sur la
façade des mairies suspense suspense les
députés ne sont pas allés hier au bout
de l'examen du texte la séance va
reprendre dans l'après-midi mais les
amendements de suppression ont tous été
rejetés à noter que les écolos et les
socialistes sont annoncés qu'ils
voteraient en faveur du texte de
renaissance contrairement à la France
insoumise on rappelle que l'euro député
Manon Aubry avait considéré en début de
semaine que le drapeau européen revoit
renvoyait le site à une forfaiture
démocratique référence au référendum de
2005 rejeté par les Français à un an des
élections européennes les divisions sur
la question européenne continue à
l'intérieur de la nupes et on va y venir
et ça divise aussi la majorité est-ce
que c'était opportun de mettre ce débat
sur la table maintenant Dominique ça
divisé la majorité présidentielle
notamment Renaissance et le modem
c'est clair qu'il y a il y a deux
niveaux d'interprétation qui se
contredisent pas forcément d'ailleurs le
premier de façon j'ai envie de dire
j'aime pas le mot mais enfin
politicienne il y a des élections
européennes qui pointent à l'horizon et
il est très clair soit dans les
réactions comme c'était prévisible
qu'une démarche de cet ordre
sème le trouble du côté du rassemblement
national et dans une partie de la gauche
hier unie puisque on voit que les
socialistes notamment restent fidèles à
ce qui a été leur credo de toujours
tandis que le les
insoumis évidemment tempêtes moi je suis
je pense deux choses je ressens deux
choses comme citoyen l'Europe est
décisive et la France que nous sommes
tous attachés a besoin de son ancrage
européen c'est l'avenir de la France
passe aussi par l'Europe pourquoi ne pas
le dire et pourquoi ne pas le redire
maintenant sous un tout autre angle
peut-être un espace suivi d'assez près
les le pourquoi du comment de cette
démarche mais obligé les mères à mettre
le drapeau européen alors que beaucoup
et je les salue le fausse spontanément
obligé les mers à mettre le drop
européen au fronton de leur mairie ça me
plonge dans une certaine perplexité on
va dire pour l'instant
[Rires]
a besoin de l'Europe a besoin de la
France je suis convaincu par
l'absolu nécessité de l'avenir de
l'Union européenne et
l'absolu nécessité de faire
de transmettre aux nouvelles générations
l'intérêt que l'Union européenne a
d'exister et à vocation à être renforcée
mais ouvrir un débat sur l'utilité
l'obligation la nécessité de mettre des
drapeaux au fronton des écoles au
fronton
des mairies franchement c'est pas ça je
vois bien qu'on essaie d'allumer des
contre-feu qu'Emmanuel Macron c'est la
macronie c'est de le faire et d'ailleurs
à chaque fois il se reprennent comme un
revers de en boomerang y compris au sein
de la majorité ça ne ça ne séduit pas
tout le monde cette proposition mais
c'est comme tout à l'heure le sujet de
la fraude c'est à dire qu'on allume on
allume les contrefeux et on se dit mais
pourquoi c'est pas déjà le cas enfin ça
paraît très logique a priori que les
mairies se doivent de elle le souhaite
d'un drapeau européen mais
Pierre c'est un sujet un de plus en
envie de dire qui divise la nuque oui ça
débute la nuit pour vivre la majorité
aussi mais si vous voulez franchement je
souffre pardon je devrais pas pour les
téléspectateurs excusez-moi chers amis
et amis es téléspectrice mais parce que
en fait vous voyez bien
vos invités sur la question de des
Outre-mer les gens ont déjà pas de quoi
subvenir à leurs besoins finir les fins
quand ils voient leurs élus leur
représentants du peuple débattre de
l'utilité la nécessité l'obligation de
mettre un drapeau elle va être compliqué
cette campagne européenne pour la nuque
je vous mets au défi je l'ai déjà dit
non c'est pas c'est je crois que c'est
fini mettez Raphaël Glucksman et Manon
aubryland en face de lui et trouver les
pointes des accords sur sur l'Union
européenne ils ont pas être très
nombreux en tout cas
liste
je serais ravi je vais essayer moi
politique d'organise le type de débat
parce que je serai ravi de les voir se
parler les uns en face des autres et
dire où sont les points de désaccord et
qu'est-ce qui justifie devant les
Français qui sont séduits par l'un ou
l'autre de les voir au partir de manière
opposée aux élections européennes ça je
trouve que c'est intéressant de
connaître du drapeau à l'organisation
laborieuse pour le moment mais peut-être
des bouchons sur un succès à l'arrivée
de du rassemblement des des gauches
aujourd'hui divisées sur ce sujet là
juste dire une chose ajouter une chose
si ce projet si cette ce projet voté
finalement avec une majorité pas
forcément géant d'ailleurs c'est pas sûr
qu'il le soit voté etc ce serait quand
même ceux qui auraient eu cette idée là
devront seulement de les doigts parce
que
ça donnera l'idée que pour l'Europe il y
a je me mets dans cette hypothèse là une
petite majorité et les autres sont des
des titres d'hiver avec les sensibilités
variées sont hostiles réticents et
l'Europe mérite un peu mieux que des
calculs que dont je crains qui soient
très politicien on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler vous reviendrez débattre
monsieur dans ce club d'abord on regarde
ce qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux
[Musique]
et dans la presse régionale on parle des
élections en Turquie
avant un double scrutin décisif en
Turquie élection présidentielle et
élections législatives qui tourne autour
de la personnalité de chef de l'État
récepté père Dean Stop ou Encore après
20 ans de règne le journal L'Alsace
s'intéresse ce matin à la diaspora Turk
qui pouvait voter jusqu'à hier soir le
journal nous dit que les 70 000 membres
de la communauté en Alsace ont été
sollicités par différents relais
religieux déployés sur le terrain
résultat des élections c'est dimanche à
noter que dans la région la diaspora
turque votre traditionnellement
Erdogan les Pyrénées Orientales aussi en
situation de crise oui c'est à la Une de
Midi Libre pour lutter contre la
sécheresse historique des mesures
restrictives entre en vigueur ce
mercredi la remise à niveau des piscines
est interdite tout comme l'utilisation
des spas l'arrosage des potagers des
espaces verts sont aussi proscrits sur
les terrains de golf un arrosage n'est
permis de 20 heures à deux heures
seulement si l'eau est réutilisé le
lavage des voitures n'est autorisé que
dans les stations de 70% de l'eau est
recyclée toutes ces restrictions courts
jusqu'au 13 juin au moins les maternités
en danger oui sud-ouest tire la sonnette
d'alarme dans les zones rurales les
déserts médicaux progressent il est de
plus en plus difficile pour les futurs
mamans de trouver un lit à proximité de
leur domicile pour accoucher sud-ouest
nous dit que l'encadrement des
rémunérations des intérimaires est en
train de créer un vent de panique sur le
l'hôpital public et en train d'aggraver
encore plus une crise qui était déjà là
bye bye oui on termine sur du foot
Presse Océan revient sur les malheurs du
FC Nantes en ce moment le club est
actuellement 17e du championnat de Ligue
1 et premier relegable l'heure est grave
et le président Kita a donc choisi de se
séparer de son entraîneur Antoine
cambouarey il est remplacé par
l'entraîneur des U19 pierre aristoui
objectif le maintien dans l'élite bonne
chance merci
la Une de Politis le projet terroriste
d'un gendarme néo-nazi pierre
c'est une enquête de Nadia souini qui a
mis la main sur un dossier qui va être
présenté aux assises à la fin du mois de
juin le premier procès en tout cas d'un
gendarme néonazi et qui projetait de
faire un acte terroriste en France ces
glaçant comme comme révélation il faut
le lire le CS c'est intéressant ça n'est
pas qu'un cas isolé c'est-à-dire qu'on a
pris le parti de raconter ce récit dans
nos pages en France on commande on
commence à prendre la mesure de du
danger de terrorisme d'extrême droite
qui est la première menace en France
en Allemagne ils ont pris les choses à
bras le corps parce que l'infiltration
des groupes terroriste des groupes
d'extrême droite dans les milieux de
l'armée et de la gendarmerie était très
présent et en France on en prend un peu
la mesure en ce moment on raconte
complaisance vis-à-vis de l'ultra-droite
conversation de tout à l'heure
merci Pierre Jacquemin merci d'avoir été
avec nous merci Steve oh merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis pour voir revoir cette
émission notre nouvelle plateforme
public sénat.fr prochain rendez-vous à
15h la séance de questions d'actualité
et à 18h son public Thomas a eu très
bonne journée à demain
[Musique]